Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How's it going?
Everything is fine.
It's Easter today!
Yes.
My daughter got me a chocolate egg from her church.
That's so sweet of her.
What kind of holidays do you have in your country?
Well, we have New Year's Day in January, of course.
Same here.
Do you make resolutions, too?
Yeah, I think that is the common tradition all around the world.
I think so, too.
How about in February?
Do you have Valentine's Day?
Yes.
By the way, I heard that you have White Day in March and Black Day in April.
Is that right?
Yes, but I think they're celebrated only in Korea.
That's interesting.
Have you seen any parades?
Not in person, but on TV.
What was the most impressive one?
A street parade in Switzerland.
Did you find anything interesting?
Yes, they were dancing with techno music.
Techno music?
Wow, I want to see that, too.
I just can't picture it.
What else?
Do you celebrate Thanksgiving?
Sure.
That reminds me of turkey and homemade gravy sauce.